hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of defeated candidates tournament
it is the only game that matters for the
tournament standing store for the future
of the world church championship because
the ding and hikaru are the only two
players that can grab second place in
defeated candidates tournament now as we
said uh many times during the coverage
uh second place usually doesn't matter
in a feeding candidates tournament
because whoever wins challenges the
world church champion in this case
magnus carlsen however magnus stated
that he is still not sure if he will be
playing or rather facing the challenger
uh so uh all of a sudden second place is
very important because if magnus for
some reason decides not to play uh then
yanipongshi who won the feeder
candidates tournament will face either
ding or hikaru uh depending uh who uh
who who gets second place now for hikaru
the good news is uh he has uh two
options he can either win this game or
draw the game because he has half a
point more than ding and he will uh
definitely get second place and the ding
only if he gets a victory against hikaru
uh he will get second place in the faded
candidates tournament so that's
basically it uh let's check it out and
see what happens uh we do have a nice
photo of this matchup there we have it
first move for ding being made by uh
president arkady dorkovich uh he played
d4 uh
uh
for for ding and that is the move that
the ding left on the board hikaru is uh
well he he looks very satisfied with
that we discuss whether ding will go for
the english or you know
he's definitely not gonna play e4 but uh
you know d4 definitely is uh maybe a
better attempt if if you need a win so
he leaves it on the board and he plays
d4 knight to f6 we have c4 e6 and now
sorry not e5 e6 uh and knight the c3
would be a bit too optimistic because
everyone is very happy playing the names
of india nowadays so he goes for knight
to f3 the so-called anti-nimso variation
d5 by hikaru going for the queen's
gambit declined knight to c3 and now c5
the very sharp semitars defense uh and
now e3c captur sun d5 is by far the most
popular so dean has to opt for um for a
bit of a sideline it's not really even a
sideline is the second most popular
option but still not the most popular
one knight to c6 we have a3 and the d
captures on c for bishop captures we
have a6 now preparing b5 and uh
a6 and now bishop back to d3 and now uh
usually something like c captures on d4
will be played here there are a couple
of other moves played but hikaru goes
for a move that is extremely rare and
the last time it was played it was uh in
1913 uh by edward lasker uh not the
world church champion emmanuel alaska
but edward alaska his long-lost cousin
not lost they you know met each other uh
but interestingly edward did not know uh
he was um cousin to emanuel asker only
after uh emmanuel uh showed him the
family tree uh then edward realized that
they were in fact related just thought
you guys wanted to know this i've even
covered a nice game by him i think it
was against uh sir thomas moore or
something like that uh but you know the
the brilliant um uh king walk a rather
uh brilliant um uh sacrifice that ended
in in a king walk checkmating the the
black king on on h2 i believe or h1
maybe something like that but do check
it out if you haven't seen it okay so a
very very rare move by hikaru d captures
and c5 bishop characters and now pawn to
b4 attacking the bishop and in the game
that i've mentioned that was played in
1913 edward lasker played bishop back to
d6 but hikaru goes for bishop to e7 and
it is now as of move 10 that we have a
completely new game so dink could not
have hoped for better than this
completely unexplored territory uh
already on move 10 and still all of the
material is on the board now
interestingly the move uh alaska played
bishop to d6 the engine likes both of
them pretty much equally so probably
something he carry decided at some point
uh we have cat we have castles by uh by
ding and now bishop to b7 getting the
bishop to this so a wonderful diagonal
bishop to be tuning also if he
encounters the bishop and the now
castles and here comes a very very uh
interesting move by being or rather a
weird approach if you consider what's
happening in the tournament uh you you
would probably expect something like
queen to e2 developing the queen
connecting the rooks then maybe playing
rook to d1 rook to c1 or a move like
maybe queen to b1 putting pressure on
that h7 pawn uh but ding plays knights
the e4 and he just straight out offers a
queen trade and in the night trade so
a very very interesting
idea all to grab control of this
diagonal so hikaru happily trades knight
captures bishop captures and now pawn to
f5 not allowing this bishop to remain
here bishop back to b1 uh you could also
play bishop to c2 but dean wants to
remaneuver the bishop over to a2 and
grab hold of this diagonal and now he
counter trades queen captures on d1 rook
captures and rook after d8 so everything
has been traded off uh
there's no way you can lose this
position so bishop to a2 going after the
e6 pawn king to f7 uh hikaru defends it
sorry about that and now pawn to h4
we have h6 now comes rook d to c1 ding
or you could also consider rocate the c1
but ding wants to keep at least some
material on the board without material
there's no way to actually win the game
bishop the d6 by hikaru and now rook to
c2 preparing to double rooks and the c
file knight to e7 and now knight to d4
uh we have bishop to d5 now as uh
you want to defend that e6 pawn it's
attacked by the knight end by the bishop
so bishop to d5 and here uh dean trades
bishop captures we have knight captures
and rook a to c1 winning the c file it's
not much but it's something rook to d7
by hikaru and now knight to b3 the
knight now is coming to c5 where it will
put pressure on hikaru's position and of
course if you trade then uh ding will
get a beautiful past uh c pawn so bishop
back to e7 uh attacking the pawn here h5
and now bishop to f6 offering a trade of
bishops and uh here okay if you go for
knight to c5 right away attacking the
rook then hikaru will just trade and
attack the district so after rook
captures let's say rook c7 and the
knight didn't really achieve all that
much on c5 so ding holds off with this
move he plays bishop to d4 first uh he
doesn't want the change to occur on b2
rather he wants it on d4 then the knight
can come to d4
but hikaru just plays e5 he chases away
the bishop bishop now comes the c5 and
now he carl plays bishop to d8
uh with the idea of re-maneuvering the
bishop over to b6 to kick away this
bishop from c5 rook to d2 now
remaneuvering the rooks over to the
d-file and knight f6 uh hikaru offers a
rook trait and the more material leaves
the board the closer hikaru is to a draw
and to a potential world chess
championship match against the ani
ponishi if magnus decides not to play so
rook captures on d7 knight captures and
now rook to d1 putting pressure on the
knight hoping for knight captures and c5
but of course knight to f6 going after
the h5 pawn and here we have bishop to
d6 now ding says all right you capture
an h5 uh but uh i'm attacking the e5
pawn which is uh a lot more important so
here hikaru goes knight to g4 defends
the e5 pawn and you can't kick it away
with f3 because the e3 pawn falls so
bishop back to c5 hoping to infiltrate
with the rook uh but now bishop the h
for going after the f2 pawn so rook the
d7 with check king the g8 and now pawn
to g3 kicking away the bishop bishop to
g5 and now king the f1 by ding starting
to bring the king into the game and what
can hikaru play here well there's one
move that pretty much
solves all of his problems with rook to
d8 uh
you kind of have to trade here there's
no good way uh for you to play this if
you don't trade if you go for something
like rook tape a7 you go after the a6
pawn then rook to d3 is very annoying uh
attacking the knight here
and then at the knight will have to move
you're going to capture on a3 so ding
will not be able to capture on a6 as
you'll be defending the spawn so here
hikaru would already be better if dean
would do something like this so really
there's nothing better than to trade
rooks whether you trade it here or you
play rook to d6 to trade it on d6 or you
bring it back to d2 but you have to
trade rook so for example captures
captures and now the game continues
bishop d6 putting pressure on the pawn
king f7 we start bringing the king into
the game everything is perfectly fine
for hikaru but this is move 35 uh ding
is lower on time than hikaru and hikaru
played bishop to d8
uh he wants the uh uh he he wants to
start pushing this pawn he wants to play
a5 and completely shatter the queen side
once the situation on the queen side is
decided that then uh it's a draw there's
nothing to play for anymore however he
missed one move from ding uh and that
move will be what uh uh what will haunt
hikaru for a very long time so feel free
to pause the video and try to find the
only move that allows ding to seize
advantage while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
brilliant idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is rook
to b7 with this move hikaru is basically
without without a move to play
but it didn't seem like this move came
as a surprise to hikar even though okay
now this is impossible because the b51
hangs he carl played f4 pretty much
instantly here so okay congratulations
to everyone who found rook to b7 but uh
you know it it it it wasn't all that all
that's clear that you absolutely had to
play this so g4 uh f4 now trying to
shatter the the pawn structure here uh
being traits captures captures and now
uh ding misses it uh here he plays e4
and it makes sense you want to play f3
you want to have a pass pawn on e4
that's able to march forward whenever
you want it but captures on f4 actually
is winning by force because uh it's not
easy to find the move here for black
best black has um
if you just don't wanna you know uh wait
for dean to do whatever he wants is
knight to f6 to go after the h5 pawn now
knight d4 after he carl captures on h5
now f5 and that's
how you achieve a victory knight to f4
uh because you have to prevent knight to
e6 and rook captures on g7 now we still
play knight to e6 characters characters
and now e7 uh is basically uh
you are unstoppable here you will not be
able to defend this position uh but the
ding played e4 instead and now he gave
hikar a wonderful opportunity to to get
back into the game but now hikaru is the
one who misses it probably because he
ding is very low on time he wanted to uh
you know uh making play faster and he
played bishop to f6 which is not a bad
move it's actually the second best move
recommended by the engine it's just that
f3 here is uh so powerful that um it's
very hard for for ding to now make a
move you cover both of these squares and
now after let's say knight to d4 because
you really want to go after that the g7
pawn now comes knight to e5 and now
after knight to f5 attacking g7 now we
simply play bishop to f6 we defend it
and everything is nicely defended once
uh the rook comes to d8 it will be ding
who might be in trouble here uh but okay
with perfect play it's a draw uh but
still after bishop to f6 by hikaru now
think has knight to d4 and now it's much
much different now the f3 square is
defended so you don't have f3 so rook to
e8 going after the e4 pawn interestingly
ding has only five minutes on the clock
hikaru has over 20 minutes uh but um
basically what link has to decide is
whether to play kink the g2 or king the
e2 you'd think you want to play pawn to
f3 and simply defend this pawn but now
the problem is knight's the e3 with
check this is just a spectacular square
for the knight and after the king moves
we're gonna play rook to e5 go after the
pawn and this will be a draw no no win
for ding uh but after king to g2 now the
position is uh very much winning for
ding because how do you play this uh it
seems like you could just grab a pawn
here but uh
not really uh you know of course if you
now capture we just play f3 and we
attack the knight and the rook so that
would be silly and if you play bishop
captures bishop captures and now knight
to f6 which of course is possible uh you
attack this pawn now we have king to f3
that's the point of of the king to g2 or
king to e2 moves and after knight
captures on h5 we're gonna play rook to
b6 finally go after this pawn rook to d8
goes after the bishop now bishop p5 and
everything is nicely defended we're
going to start capturing here at some
point we will win the b2 pawn as well
and hopefully win the game but still
it's not all that clear uh probably with
perfect play you can win but he car
would have excellent chances
at finding moves here however after
knight the e5 that he carl played now
just knight to f5 and black is seriously
running out of moves
again knight to c4 is a very nice try
here and we will show it because we you
really want to go after this a3 pawn but
now bishop p7 uh attacking the bishop
you want to eliminate it and then gain
access to the g7 square bishop captures
knight captures with cher king f7 knight
to g6 opening up a discovery king goes
back now f3 now you defend the pawn
knight captures and okay you can still
play it but now uh the a6 pawn will be
lost at some point we're gonna start
pushing our our pawn uh the f4 pawn will
also be lost uh yeah so very little hope
of saving it so he carl played f3 check
uh king the g3 the only uh move that
allows dink to retain a winning position
now knight to c4 and of course bishop to
e7 so a very similar idea to what we've
discussed only with the inclusion of f3
check
we have bishop to b2 now uh putting
pressure on a3 but not allowing the
trade of the bishops and king captures
on f3 bishop captures an a3 and now we
have king to g3 now you are ready to
start pushing your pawn knight to e5 and
here bishop back to c5 so not rushing
anything still putting pressure under
the g7 pawn knight to f7 hikaru stops
this and now pawn to f3 defending his e4
pawn
so just keeping it very very
solid and not allowing hikaru a single
idea
and now uh you are basically in suk
zuang you can't move the knight because
rook captures on g7 you can't move the
king anywhere because the knight hangs
with
rogue captures and f7 this is impossible
because bishop covers that
one thing you could do is play something
like rook to a8 to prevent ding from
going after this pawn but now you no
longer control the e file and now e5 e6
e7 and that's it you just lose the game
uh of course uh the knight cannot
capture because of rook captures on g7
and you completely fall apart so what
can you do here well he carl played a
bishop to c1 it it's a move that doesn't
completely ruin his position uh and now
uh ding is the play and of course rook
to a7 uh he had to give something bishop
to d2 now comes to rook captures on a6
and bishop to e1 with check hikaru still
finds moves and of course he will do
anything he can not to lose this game
and you know still keep the possibility
of playing magnus for the title or
rather not magnus playing nipple for the
title king but also maybe even magnus
because if uh
you know magnus agrees to play and the
nipple decides not to play for some
reason then hikaru would face magnus
even this is possible so king to g2 we
have bishop to c3 now again just waiting
to see what happens and rook to a7 dean
goes back we have knight to g5 and
knight the e7 with check king h8 uh
sorry king to h8 now knight back to g6
with the are king to g8 and knight to
the e7 with check and now ding could
have gone for rook to b7 and then after
the b5 pawn but then you maybe allow
some trickery with knight to the e6
going after the bishop so ding does not
want to allow hikaru to even have that
uh glimpse of a hope you know
of saving the game
uh so king the h8 now comes knight to d5
attacking the bishop and this is what
being came up with and you will be
extremely impressed when you see it
bishop to b2 rook to a2 attacking the
bishop we have uh bishop back to c1 and
now rook to c2 attacking the bishop
bishop to a3 and now dean plays bishop
to e3 and he was in this position and 58
that hikaru nakamura resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
with the bishop covering the c1 square
rook to a2 will trap the bishop uh and
that's it there's no no way to play this
uh it's completely resigned
it's impossible to even find the move
here if you play something like rook to
a8 the guard the bishop it doesn't
matter we still play rook to a2 and now
what do you play yeah you have to play
something you you can play rook to rook
to a a6 or something and then comes the
bishop to c1 and you still win even
though the bishop is guarded you will
not be able to capture because now the
rook hangs so there's that so basically
the only thing you will have after
bishop to e3 is to give up this knight
for the two pawns characters and
captures
in order to maybe save the bishop this
way but still king f3 we go after the
rook and now after the rook moves we
just go knight to f4
you still can't save the bishop because
let's say knight to g6 check will pick
up the rook and after the rook moves now
we just play uh bishop to c5 we defend
our pawn here and again we go after the
bishop or you know try any anything so
you don't even get to save this bishop
and uh
win a pawn for this so the position
would be uh pointless uh to continue so
after bishop to e3 uh with a heavy heart
hikaru nakamura resigns the game and
another brilliant victory for dingler
and who had a slow start everyone was
going like yeah what is it what is this
happening a 2800 player you know can't
get a win uh but ding finishes in clear
second place a full point and a half
behind yanipanishi because uh well uh
ian just played the the the most
incredible candidates tournament uh
pretty much ever
and he finished with nine and a half out
of 13 which is the most points anyone
ever achieved since this system was
introduced in 2013 so that's uh pretty
pretty incredible uh but yeah we're
going to discuss the standings as the
first
game is still going on while i'm
recording this ferruja has an advantage
he's trying to beat fabi and
we'll see what happens we're going to
cover at least one more game from the
final round of the candidates tournament
check out the standings and discuss
everything a little bit more but yeah so
far uh as the as the situation stands
magnus is the world champion nepo is the
challenger if uh magnus decides not to
play then nipple will face uh being
learned for the title of fiji world
classical champion uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it i would
like to wish a very happy birthday to
matthew uh aurelius and i would like to
thank pascal 62 today revoir uh gregory
thomas gideon franklin and jim tran for
a contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
feeder candidates tournament until it
finishes uh so thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day